hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today were back out monster on a
world again and today we're gonna be
tackling Valle hazaki doing one of my
solo guides again Valle Haziq is one of
the three other dragons you have to
fight in the story quest I keep
forgetting the name but it has to do
with the one where you have to track the
three ancient elder dragon tracks I do
have a video on that if that is
troubling you so definitely go check
that out it's one of the more recent
videos I posted but he is going to be
one of the three and is located in the
rotten Vale so let's get started I
personally think he is the easiest of
the three but that's completely up to
debate and based off your opinion if
you've watched one of my guides before
then you know we're gonna start doing
next but if you're new we're gonna start
going over the physiology report so
let's get started and first yes I read
the comments for people correcting me
the word is physiology and not
psychology thank you for that and I
finally got it right this time
but going based off the report it says
Valle hazaki has weak points in the tail
underbelly and head with detail
underbelly head and legs being breakable
or severable now depending on what your
weapon is you want to hit him in a
different spot sharp weapons want to aim
for the tail blunt weapon should always
aim for the head and ranged weapon
should always aim for the head or tail
looking off to the right you could see
his weaknesses and you want to have a
weapon that either has fire or dragon
element if you're using an element or
blast or stun ever using an ailment now
that we're done with the report let's
talk about his equipment so the weapon
you use as well as the armor is
completely up to you but a few key
things that you want to use our mega
potions like always the vitality mantle
which we'll get into detail of why later
besides the obvious of preventing damage
on a few hits and probably the most
important one for this fight is gonna be
no berries vel leaks this type of gas
called F Olivia I'm not entirely sure if
I pronounced that right but basically
it's this dark grey cloud on the floor
of gas it will do minor damage but if
dealt enough it will actually cut your
health bar in half so bye-bye to any of
the food you just ate before the fight
all you have to do those eat in no berry
and the effect goes away there is some
in the areas in which you fight him but
not a whole lot so definitely want to
come prepared before the fight next
we're gonna be going over some of the
key moves to watch out for and then the
areas in which you fight him in so let's
start with the moves one of the easiest
to dodge and probably the most punishing
for him is the move where he sprays his
grace smoke clouds forward really fast
the move will start from right and
continue left until he stops moving his
head he only he also moves a little bit
for
so just move to the side and punish his
tail or belly when he's doing this move
he will usually do some moves when he
tries to get space from you by jumping
away which can cause some damage so
definitely watch his feet on that so try
not to attack him too much do a little
bit of damage back up a bit because he
might try to jump away and we're not
trying to lose health in this fight
sometimes he will stand up though on his
hind legs and sprayed those gas clouds
in a widespread area once again if hit
by those just pop a null berry and
you'll be completely fine another
standing move he likes to do is what is
this charge up move where he releases
his gas clouds around him in a vicious
spray you can either run away or flash
pot hint to completely stop it or hit
him a few times until your blast
triggers if you have a blast opening he
should stop charging if you have the
space try to lure them in areas without
gas clouds to give you that extra
advantage and also your vitality mental
which we talked about earlier should
prevent you from being affected by the
gas clouds as shown in this clip I was
in there for a pretty decent time and
didn't get affected whatsoever yes it
does drain the vitality mentals health
bar a little bit but you are getting
some decent hits in as well another move
he'll do is what I called the head swing
it's pretty simple I'm pretty basic
he basically swipes his head on the
floor in front of him he basically goes
from right to left or left to right so
either way be far away from him or
behind him to avoid the move those are
the moves he'll be throwing at you
throughout the fight so let's get into
the areas so the area I started on is
mostly this land area with a tiny
electric pool in the back there isn't
much here except the entrance to his
nest is off to the right and you can use
the little ledge to mount and the mini
slope leading from the entrance to use
any sliding attacks reppin has he also
when he tries to limp to his nest he
will go around toward the electric area
do not follow that you you will get
blocked by an invisible wall and you
will take damage from the water just go
through the normal entrance as if you
were just going the regular way and you
should be completely fine like I said
you can use that mini slope leading from
his entrance to do any sliding attacks
your weapon has now I'm not entirely
versed on every single weapon in monster
hunter world I do use dual blades
basically 100% of the time and I do know
that they have a sliding move which is
very very deadly and very elegant
now I'm not entirely sure every weapon
has a type of sliding animation but if
it does have one you can use that mini
slope to do any sliding moves and get
some extra damage on him
so definitely utilize that while you can
the next area is also going to be an
area surrounded by the electric water
with some water
as well in the middle next to some
ledges this area is also pretty useless
except another ledge like I said by the
middle water source which can be used
for mounting as well and some no berries
around the edges toward the water if you
need some the third area though is
actually one of the areas you fight the
RO de the odo Garin which is that
bleeding monster somewhere in the rotten
Vale there will be some gear O's there
as well too they would usually get in
your way but if you're lucky Ken
paralyzed Vall and knock him over to
give you some free hits I wasn't able to
record it because my footage got
corrupted but trust me it did happen one
time and you will get some free hits
from it and then the last area is his
nest
it does have some water on the side so
also watch out for that and some gears
at the top and a slope of dead bodies
which is the entire thing he's resting
on you can also slide down that for a
possible mount and that's it you have
all the tools utilized to fight Valle
you have his weaknesses every single
thing about the weapons you should be
using where to hit him in the areas in
which you fight him in I hope you guys
did enjoy that video if you guys did it
please try to give it a like really does
help me out I have tons of these guys
coming I did beat all the bosses so far
except the last one which I don't want
to spoil the ending boss I did beat but
there's one all the way up in a hunter
rank 50 just in case for anybody that
doesn't want spoilers I won't say
anything but there is a boss that is
only accessible up at that point but
I've beaten all the main story bosses so
I'm gonna be working on the other two
other dragons and then the final boss as
well getting the videos out hopefully in
the last couple weeks of it you guys can
enjoy those but like I said if you guys
did enjoy the video please sure to give
it a like subscribe if you're new I post
a lot of Monster Hunter World content
like solo guides tons of news and tips
and all that type of stuff regarding
Monster Hunter World my two most recent
videos of that are gonna be popping up
on screen if you guys didn't miss those
thank you guys for the love and support
on these solo guides really is helping
me out you guys are the best
and with that guys hope you have a great
rest of your day and peace out